in just a few days now catholic
charities of southern nevada will mark
80 years of service
to those most in need in our community
and in commemoration staff are cooking
up a feast this morning
chefs are already up and they're
prepping for the big day hector mejia
live this morning inside the kitchen
hopefully
not getting in the way and he has the
story live hector good morning to you
sir
good morning guys and you know what no i
will not get in the way i don't want to
interrupt the special mission and have a
cooking marathon similar to what they do
for thanksgiving
or christmas day and a lot is happening
right now a lot of preparation
i want to introduce executive chef june
lau all right
what are we chopping up right now good
morning to you sir good morning uh this
is our texas style brisket
that's been cooking for uh we cooked it
for six hours in the oven
six long hours what else is going on the
plate smells delicious already
yeah it comes with the baked beans and
corn the cob
sounds delicious so we have a lot of
people here in the kitchen getting
active and
this is all for friday starts at 10
o'clock this morning here at catholic
charities
giving away a special warm plate to
celebrate 80 years and i also want to
introduce
i want to introduce leslie carmine here
with catholic charities
a lot has happened over 80 years
absolutely i don't think i could talk
about all of that in a short time
but we started with humble beginnings
you know back in 1941 when there was a
great need
there was a lot of hard economic times
at that time and
we saw that need and formed a program
that could help people
now during the pandemic a lot of
families falling on hard times for the
first time in their life
yeah fortunately we're seeing that again
and we've never really seen this kind of
thing before so
we're kind of learning as we go but
we're learning from the past
and taking steps in the future to make
sure we can help people become
self-sufficient
and you know be okay again and just
about how many people do you guys help a
day
a lot just over four thousand uh we
through all of our programs all the
services that are going out we have over
2400
meals on wheels clients that receive
food every single day
you know they're not able to leave their
homes so we're very happy that we're
able to provide that
and thankful that our community is here
to support us as well
leslie thank you for having us this
early in the morning while the chick the
by the chicken
for all the chicken see i'm hungry about
the kitchen
chicken well the kitchen is busy right
now so with it being april
it's also volunteer month we'll talk
about ways you can volunteer from home
and help out catholic charities that's
still ahead in the next half hour for
now reporting live hector mejia
with chicken on my mind back to you well
i think you're in the right place hector
put your order in now
you got two hours thank you